it certainly doesn't look promising
and opinion is divided over its merits
either you like it or you don't I don't
there are plenty of varieties but love
Scouts should always include a fried egg
pickles and red beets my mother used to
make it it was tasty with Friday it's
with beetroot fish onions that's all I
know it's brilliant I have to have it
twice a year and it's without fish
believe it or not not necessarily the
centuries-old seafarers dish is made
with or without and if you're in Hamburg
the obvious place to buy fish is at the
market by the docks
a traditional tourist attraction in its
own right you're far from here there's a
restaurant that's famous for its laps
cars the old commercial room its walls a
testimony to the celebrities past and
present who have dined here over the
decades German film legend Hans Albers
jazz trumpeter and singer Louis
Armstrong singer Joe Cocker or Woody
Allen it's been in the family for three
generations and is run by a Reinhardt
rock his father put loves cows on the
menu in the 1960s it was a dish made
from leftovers death skulls covers love
to hang Rises loves cows was only served
on the voyage home when the ship's cook
cleared out his storerooms everything he
had was pickled gherkins and red beets
in the onions which kept forever anyway
Plus potatoes and he mixed it all
together and came up with this pulp
that's called loves cows IEMs desi claps
:
laughs cars isn't made here by a
veterans ship chef but by columns queasy
Menza from Ghana he's been making it
here for 12 years
Rinda boost throw in beef brisket onions
salt pepper take it out after 2 or 3
hours then back in with the stock and
mashed potatoes right in deform it cut
off your polygamist it's easy boy he's
even made the dish back home yeah last
year I was on vacation in Ghana and I
made it with a couple of colleagues it's
something new for Africans it's a little
like corned beef that the people there
already know it was good unfortunately
they ate it with bread instead of with
beets pickles and fried eggs the
clientele at the old commercial room and
mainly tourists more than 500 portions
of flats cows are served up here each
week I'm surprised and I think I'll eat
it again if I'm in Hamburg some of my
friends they say it's just like beef and
potatoes but for me it's just a taste
legend Finnish Turkish markers the taste
is new but really good I'd recommend it
we're then at the dogs album which isn't
a restaurant but a club serving the
German seamen's mission
Klaus Poland and his colleagues live up
to the motto serving seafarers with
dignity the lab scarce here is strictly
with fish as a side dish
about safety English Buckeye vision well
that brings out the taste of otherwise
it would be too bland but the fish gives
it a little spice some serve lob scales
with pickled or salted herring
there are also recipes where the fish is
ground up with the potatoes and me I get
to be laps cows a treat for the taste
buds even if not perhaps for the eyes
and a nice portion of North German
tradition